добре, я думаю, що ми відреагували, як могли,
і стріляли, серед іншого, ми
ініціювали санкції, і поступово
ми також посилили економічні
санкції, і я вважаю, що ці санкції
завдали шкоди Росії, вони підвищили вартість
цієї незаконної дії щодо захоплення
Криму, а також НАТО вирішило
посилити  це взагалі оборона, насправді
можна сказати, що президент Путін зробив
внесок у збільшення
інвестицій у оборону в усьому НАТО, тому ми зробили
кроки, які могли, і стріляли, я думаю, що
миротворчі сили були б
механізмом для виконання Мінської
угоди, нічого не сталося, насправді
, немає  прогрес не будь-яка
причина полягає в тому, що у вас немає механізму для
забезпечення виконання та реалізації угоди про засоби, тому
для її реалізації, очевидно,
Україні неможливо організувати
вибори, поки у вас все ще є
обстріли та вбивства в цьому районі, тому
ви повинні зупинити цю змову, але ви
потрібно створити мир у регіоні, перш ніж ви
зможете просунутися вперед у
виконанні основного питання
як він це представив, це може бути пасткою,
тому що він запропонував невелику
миротворчу місію, яка дозволила б лише
миротворцям вздовж лінії зіткнення
між вільною Україною та
окупованою Україною і лише для захисту
спостерігачів OEC, що я пропоную.  більш
потужні миротворчі сили, які також
створюють мандат для контролю реального
міжнародного кордону між Україною та
Росією, щоб зупинити
приплив військової техніки та солдатів з
Росії